until not long ago we served as Attorney
General of the United States tonight
he's speaking on camera for the first
time since he left the Trump
administration
there are currently rumors swirling that
he could run for the Senate seat that he
held for two decades will he do that
Jeff Sessions joins us on sex tonight
Sarah thanks so much for coming on Thank
You Tucker good to be with you are you
running for Senate yes we will file our
papers tomorrow so you are running for
the seat that you held you were I think
after the coach the Alabama football
team the most popular person the
statement left do you regret that you
left in the first place well I had a
great tenure at the Department of
Justice in so many different ways and I
don't ever worry about regretting things
like that we were able to serve be able
to push the Trump agenda and do it in an
honorable way and it was some extra
great experience I spent 15 years in the
department yep so I don't regret that
and it was an honor to serve and I am
it's not my seat in the Senate but I
believe I have something to give I have
some convictions that I think need to be
pushed we need to get some Republicans
moving they haven't been pushing hard
enough to advance the Trump agenda and
so that's what I look forward to doing
and and if I think I can contribute to
that so politics famously intruded on
your tenure at the Department of Justice
we can get to that in a minute but it
raised the question of your relationship
with President Trump which I think you
addressed fairly directly in a new
political ad I don't know if this is
aired anywhere until now but here it is
when I left president Trump's cabinet
did I write a tell-all book no did I go
on CNN and attack the president nope
have I said a cross word about our
president not one time and I'll tell you
one first that would be dishonorable I
was there to serve his agenda not mine
second the president's doing a great job
for America and Alabama and he has my
strong support
he has your strong support do you have
his strong support well I hope so I
think he will respect my work I was
there for the Trump agenda every day I
was in the Senate no doubt about that
was the first Republican first senator
to endorse him yes we pushed his
immigration agenda his trade agenda and
began to work to a more realistic
foreign policy that doesn't give us an
endless wars I think he was right about
all three of those yes that's where the
American people are and this Republican
Congress and the whole Congress needs to
listen to that well ironically you were
one of the by my count one of the very
few people in the administration who
agreed with him on his signature issues
most didn't and work to undermine them
as we've seen over three years but you
got into it on the question of Russia
you recused herself from the
investigation he was furious about that
he's never stopped complaining he
recently was complaining about it do you
regret that decision no III did the
thing I had to do under the rules of the
Department of Justice I the the senior
advisors told me that this is what the
rules require the regulations required
and I read them and I don't think there
was any out for me but I know how
painful it was for the president this is
the whole thing was very painful for him
and he saw this as a pivotal moment but
painful and is prolonged as it was it
did clear him of Russian collusion and
I'm certainly glad that finally happened
he's very popular in the state of
Alabama as you know and as your ad
suggests you don't want him to come out
against you of course are you going to
talk to them about it well I do a will
and I look forward to having that
opportunity it hadn't been provided at
this moment but I would like to be able
to go to the people of Alabama and tell
them with all honesty I believe in this
agenda I was for this agenda before
President Trump announced that I
supported it when he was president when
he was running for president I supported
him and if I returned to the Senate I
will know senator in the Senate will be
more effective in advancing president
Trump's agenda then I would be I believe
that and I was I was there before Trump
arose and you were making the same case
that he's making now what about your
fellow Republicans who remain in the
Senate do you think after three years
they buy the Trump agenda Josh Tucker I
think some of them must still
standoffish if some of them almost give
the impression that maybe he'll just
fail or it won't happen and we won't
have to deal with it but ending
lawlessness at the border is a
bipartisan overwhelming issue standing
up to China defending American
manufacturing standing up against our
cheating and fraud and abuse it's a
bipartisan powerful issue Trump is right
on both of those and fine all wars I saw
recently that veterans opposed didn't
think military efforts in Iraq were
justified by 64% American people think
we are too committed in too many endless
wars brother Trump is right about that
so I think this represents some change
for the Republican establishment and
many of the Democrats are totally
opposed to it but we should be able to
put together a majority we should drive
this issues we could take it to the
American people and name names and show
who's for what and make them vote that's
what I'd like to see us do naming names
would be a great public service quickly
we've moved from Russia to Ukraine the
president apparently is gonna be
impeached what do you make of that I
just cannot see an impeachment case here
it's it's just been a continuous
political attack on him from day one
things that people have done that are
perfectly innocent I felt some of that
myself or created and twisted to be
something evil and improper and I
believe the president has conducted
himself or in this matter within the law
and I don't believe there's anything
close to an impeachment case I think the
Democrats
basically vote it it looks like slink
away yeah and let the Senate rejected
senator attorney general and now once
again Senate candidate Jeff Sessions
thank you for coming on tonight thank
you does be